Sir Harry croteau room as you said you
want people to understand science how do
you think people from poor countries can
get the education of science and
understand it worked the government of
poor countries should do to make people
understand science well they should get
involved in my geo set program because
that is aimed at creating this globally
accessible cache of educational material
and make it accessible throughout the
world I mean that's what google and
youtube and wikipedia have done they
they have created this infrastructure
that allows you to in people like
Wikipedia really know something to put
it on the web young people can make a
movie and make it accessible and google
has allowed you to find it and Microsoft
and other organizations Apple have
worked hard on producing the software
and the hardware to do that so the the
infrastructure to get the educational
material to the teacher is there I still
think the teacher is very important I
mean there will be kids who can learn by
themselves from the internet but I think
the teacher is there and the key skill
the teacher must have is to be able to
create enthusiasm in young people for
something particularly something for
which they have some particular ability
and encourage that gift that all of us
have for something creative and the
infrastructure is there to help the
teachers to do that we can now record
all the great teachers and with we're
starting to do that and what's more I'm
finding we're finding that
undergraduates and graduates are very
good at creating educational material
and they ferret out things that are
totally unsuspected so look at my geo
set program tell it to your government
people and get involved and make a
contribution to this
and wikipedia has shown that working
together we can create something
fantastic something which far outweighs
anything that any single organization
can do I mean scientific science at
lapina Britannica it's a fantastic
compendium 200 years of work has gone
into it but it's not accessible in the
way the internet is it was a click of a
mouse you can get moving images but a
click of a mouse you can download
educational material that you can
distribute this click of the mouse you
can see a great teacher teaching this is
a paradigm shift for education and we
must really explore ways and find the
best ways of encouraging governments to
put some of their efforts into this and
making a global network of caches each
one in maybe in universities or teaching
institutions and making it accessible
from everywhere from South Africa to
South America to Malaysia to India and
then perhaps we will be able to make
sure that children in particular are
taught how to determine what is true and
what is patently not true that's the
most important aspect of Education and
science is the only philosophical
construct that can reliably determine
truth